in this video we're gonna try to figure
out what one-half plus one-third is
equal to and like always i encourage you
to pause this video and try to figure it
out on your own
all right now let's work through this
together and it might be helpful to
visualize one-half and one-third
so this is a visualization of one-half
if you view this entire bar as a whole
then we have shaded in half of it and if
you wanted to visualize one-third it
looks like that so you could view this
as this half plus this gray third here
what is that going to be equal to
now one of the difficult things is we
know how to add if we have the same
denominator so if we had a certain
number of halves here and a certain
number of halves here well then we would
know how many halves we have here but
here we're trying to add halves to
thirds so how do we do that
well we try to set up a common
denominator now what do we mean by a
common denominator well what if we could
express
this quantity and this quantity in terms
of some other denominator
and a good way to think about it is is
there a multiple of two and three and
it's simplest when you use the least
common multiple and the least common
multiple of two and three is six so can
we express one-half in terms of sixths
and can we express one-third in terms of
sixths so let me just start with 1
over
2 and i made this little fraction bar a
little bit longer because you'll see why
in a second well if i want to express it
in terms of 6 to go from halves to 6 i
would have to multiply the denominator
by 3.
but if i want to multiply the
denominator by 3 and not change the
value of the fraction i have to multiply
the numerator by 3 as well
and to see why that makes sense
think about this
so this what we have in green is exactly
what we had before but now by
multiplying the numerator and the
denominator by three i've expressed it
into sixths so notice i have six times
as many divisions of the whole bar
and the green part which you could view
as the numerator i now have three times
as many so these are now sixths so i now
have three sixths instead of one half so
this is the same thing as three over six
and i want to add that or if i want to
add this to what well how do i express 1
3 in terms of 6
well the way that i could do that it's 1
over 3. i would want to take each of
these thirds and make them into two
sections
so
to go from thirds to six i'd multiply
the denominator by two but i'd also be
multiplying the numerator by two and to
see why that makes sense notice this
shaded in gray part is exactly what we
have here but now we took each of these
sections and we made them into two
sections so you multiply the numerator
and the denominator by two instead of
thirds instead of three equal sections
we now have six equal sections that's
what the denominator times two did
instead of shading in just one of them i
now have shaded in two of them because
that one thing that i shaded has now
turned into two sections and that's what
multiplying the numerator by two does
and so this is the same thing as 3 6
plus this is going to be 2 6. then you
could see it here this is 1 6 2 6
and now that everything is in terms of 6
what is it going to be well it's going
to be a certain number of sixths if i
have three of something plus two of that
something well it's going to be five of
that something in this case the
something is sixths so it's going to be
five sixths
i have trouble saying that and you can
visualize visualize it right over here
this is three of the sixths one two
three plus two of the six one two gets
us to five sixths but you could also
view it as this green part was the
original half and this gray part was the
original one third but to be able to
compute it we expressed both of them in
terms of sixths